I had I know I love that I had no idea
coming on until last night I miss you so
much La feels your missing pres I was I
just loved it I was last night I was in
bed and I was like oh crap I was like I
didn't know Christy was coming on
honestly I didn't even know Dave was
going to be here you were like wait what
are you doing here oh we're doing a show
now when did y'all first meet you've
known each other for years right did you
Bond over food 2004 when I first opened
my restaurant yeah oh here so you were
living here I was living in New York um
when I had first met John and yeah I'm
30 now we don't even 20 years yeah um we
always hit up Mom fuku Noodle Bar it was
right by our house we lived in East
Village and we went there 3 four times a
week and then I just fell in love with
him that's right great food well it's
hard not to fall in love with you especi
they cook so well but where where did
Your Love of Cooking star I'll start you
with David I think with my mom she's
just still was the best cook I've ever
met and that was the only way my family
sort of communicated was through food
never anything else but I there's some
Fair
I think it's like our common Asian Bond
though too I I think um a lot of my
family at least there weren't a lot of
like there wasn't a lot of like physical
affection kiss like kisses and I love
you but food was so important in our
family and now looking back and having
children I do realize that I'm very I'm
very I mean I smother them with love but
they also get a ton of great food I know
I think it's so great when you learn at
such a young age how to cook or to be in
a kitchen and how to like that's amazing
I'm the
opposite you know but you you have two
boys do they help in the kitchen out uh
yes four and two hoo and Gus and T Test
they they uh tell me what to cook they
try to help and I'm their private chef
and no matter what I make they almost
never eat so it's a problem for me that
actually makes me feel good cuz when I
do cook I'm like do you know how hard
this was for me I don't do this and I
feel like I did a good job and they do
not eat it and I'm like it makes me feel
good that you're an actual chef and yeah
they just are like hard past where's the
mac and cheese yeah they want mac and
cheese they want all shades of brown
Foods beige my son eats nothing anything
beige anything mine I even it's gotten
to the point where I I definitely take
orders but I have to actually just at
this point with Miles I said the other
day he doesn't eat vegetables and I mean
like has not a carrot stick it's just
like a big F son will not yeah he's like
absolutely no one wants to admit to that
but then like I was like oh no it goes
past that like I can offer him a root
beer FL like he doesn't want to try that
he doesn't want to I'm like please try
this Coca-Cola like and then I'm like
why am I being why am I trying it's just
is the same though he won't I have to
sneak it in into a cup that is colorful
that you can't tell what the color is
and that's how I sneak it in it's like a
juice or a smoothie he will not do it
and he will smell it out and be like
this is a vegetable and he is like hard
against it yeah I mean and it's like I I
could make him sit there you know
whatever but it just doesn't work he'll
he'll sit me out
he will be like oh this table all night
long before kids you're like if they
don't eat what I make then they're going
to bed hungry I'm like no what would you
like
sir no I will say if my son were here
eat I have sent him to bed
hungry I cuz usually I'm tired I'm like
I just did this if you didn't like it
that's your problem I'm like I'm like I
said I made exactly what you said and
then whatever um so you you now have
more family members you been on the show
now I know how is it going we have two
new little babies crazy it's wild I I
love it's chaotic obviously um Ren is
six he just turned six months or sorry
seven months and Essie just turned a
year and that you know that that small
difference is all the is huge when
they're that tiny um and Luna and miles
are just like immersed in activities and
so many different things and everybody's
got at this stage as a parent is very
hard oh my God the Girl Scouts stuff the
we're in cookie season you want them to
be engaged that's me too but then it's
just like there's no way to feasibly
make all of these things and I ask them
I say what is one activity we should
remove and miles is always like tennis
he doesn't like tennis cuz it's too like
one on one he can't get away with any of
his bull crap and then uh with Luna
she's like nothing and this one she does
everything that's my daughter same thing
um well SD just turned one and there
were some photos from her birthday like
this one
yeah you're like like this one that's
the only one y'all make the cutest no
y'all make the cutest children ever
they're so beautiful wait and then
there's this one this one's fun
what that it seems expensive what was
broken it was immediately after I
honestly don't know because that is a
rental home and so then I realized that
they're probably going to see that or
they they saw it for sure um but yeah my
reflex time like I used to just like
with Luna like oh I would it would I
would have caught that in a second this
one I watched it Go Bo du du du and then
I just let it happen yeah yeah that's
having more than one kid you're like
it's fine the worst is how proud she was
after she she usually like they cry like
oh I did something yeah she's just yeah
she's our tough cookie oh that yeah I
get it girls girls and boys they're so
different that was the look at their new
show Christy and D Dy out you can see it
on free form and Hulu so explain this
show to everybody well Christy and I
have been wanting to do this together
for a long time and we wanted to
highlight some of the best restaurants
in Los Angeles and so many good ones so
many yeah and have great conversations
with very interesting amazing people do
you know what I was actually I was
coming from a place of like there's
nowhere good to eat anymore and then I
this guy comes up with this incredible
list of and then it opened up my eyes my
palette my everything to different
worlds some of the chefs that we got to
eat dine with and speak to completely
changed my life completely changed my
outlook I mean I'm sure you know like
when it comes to work and food when it
becomes like your work it's the passion
like can can dull out when you have four
kids like every but reignited my fire
for incredible food yeah and it's I
think that's good too timing as well
just cuz I think the you know the
industry was hit so hard with Co like
all those restaurants so many clothes
like you know so to highlight them is
incredible as well yeah we actually have
restaurants that are that are reopening
now um because of the show so that's
amazing I didn't even know that that's
crazy but they were hit really hard like
a lot of great places went out but how
did you pick there was an initial list
of like a hundred and I don't think we
could have ever have done it justice so
hopefully there's more seasons so we can
cover all the awesome restaurants that
we just put it on you don't have to
watch it just put it on the television
and just let just get those ratings I'm
like I don't even know how neelen works
but like I assume you're all neelon
families I do I don't know how they work
either every time someone says rating
I'm like what like I don't know um
anyway you had an the greatest exit at a
job that I've heard of um so before
being becoming a chef you worked like an
office job I did and how did this end
David well I wanted to make sure that I
was going to burn all the bridges so I
couldn't go back well done and honestly
I told everyone I was going to go to
cooking school so I had no choice but I
uh got really drunk at a Christmas party
and I told a lot of people how I thought
about the job and um yeah yeah oh and
amazingly enough they didn't ask you
back no not a surprise I know but I feel
like a lot of people I've heard people
exiting jobs like this and I'm like
that's such a goal I mean very few
people are inspired by the movie office
space but oh my God I love office space
my gosh yes Max machine out the window
done or that traffic scene even the very
beginning it's so true you get to the
Lane and it stops
why I know every time yes oh God what a
great movie well I have to say this to
John's birthday was last month John's
greatest gift is you cuz I'm telling you
what this party first of all was insane
like looked insane no and then also your
gift we couldn't air your gift um this
is daytime TV but I saw one of
oh my
[Music]
God it's on a big screen if you know me
too I am not a performer at this that's
you seem like you'd be like this person
out but you're not like behind the
scenes like you're actually more like
reserved so to see you give a LP dance
they let me come the night before for
rehearsal and they're like rehearsal
like it's just a la dance like what are
you thinking and I was like no no I need
a rehearsal and uh and we did it and
having to lie to John was so crazy cuz
and then just the so who who was the
rehearsal man for my S salana okay yeah
so she was I had to lick her face we
went we did we did like the we did top
to bottom rehearsal oh my God and then I
had 48 hours to plan it because I didn't
it was Christmas and I didn't realize I
was like oh my God he's going to be 45
that's kind of a big deal and then I
love 50 Cent so I figured that he should
love 5050
Cent he
yes and so that throwback because John
and I have so many memories at the Box
in New York have you been no anyone been
the old school good times oh man guys
you don't know what you're in for but it
is incredible we do now we do that is
the kind of stuff not actually that is
tame for the box but um well now I just
that's a tease now it was so much fun
and they were so cool and 50 like overd
delivered and I completely negotiated
myself like probably like three times
the rate oh oh like for him to show up
for the I like yeah it started out at a
low number and then I took it to like a
I'm a bad negotiator my first words were
I want you to feel well
compensated we the same I'm not good at
that you have to have other people make
those calls no yeah I was on it I had I
got high price yeah we're the worst okay
um we have a food game next cuz why not
okay are you down for a food game next
bar down you're going to have to play
anyway but cool so let's do another
commercial break Chrissy and Dave D out
is on free form and Hulu check it out
y'all we'll be right
[Music]
[Applause]
back thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home